I want to warn everybody out there that
this podcast this is a Monday and this
podcast is gonna be sick the bomb no
it's gonna be as good because we're
gonna do some [ __ ] I mean I'm I'm fired
up to really make this podcast and I
don't use this word often but Titanic
make it oh wow yeah ask me how I'm doing
how are you doing man I'm chill like a
turkey after Thanksgiving chillin like a
turkey F know I'm chill
like in Turkey after Thanksgiving
because think about it all turkeys are
like oh oh oh [ __ ] the ones that didn't
get slaughtered yeah they live another
season 360 foe we go through a lot of
them self probably goes through about a
pound
probably a turkey a [ __ ] week that
little that kid he just eats a sliced
turkey honey maple nothing like a little
honey maple from Whole Foods do you
think every Turk is going oh thank you
yep I do
I think there's my first thing I thought
about those turkeys are going woo we
were when we were hunting turkey in that
dangerous pursuit what killers no mr.
Rogan and myself and Steve Rinella and
Steve said well the thing about turkeys
got to remember is that that everybody
wants to eat a turkey yeah it's not it's
not just it's not just people everybody
wants to kill a turkey sees anyone
anywhere they run away which is why you
got to cover your faces when you hunt so
when we hunted turkeys we were wearing
essentially in German camouflage ninja
yes but but with leaves fake leaves and
you wear like a net with fake leaves if
they see anything and they run away now
their life is a turkey it's a tough life
they roost in trees so though I think
during the night they'll go up into a
tree and then during the day they come
down so they'll stuff in the tree go the
turkeys are always on Oh Mike you're
like they are like Dwight Howard at a
[ __ ] transsexual party that's just
[ __ ] that's right freaking out they
don't want anyone to film uh-huh no
don't approach them uh there that's what
they are they are they know their food
their food on two legs did not look cool
though they look they look like
dinosaurs nice an animal
they're tall and aggressive I mean I
definitely the video of me being chased
around the car by a turkey I've seen a
turkey yeah well I got chased by a group
of turkeys over and over again around a
really large turkeys with smaller they
were they were literally and I'm not
exaggerating four feet high the other
big boys and not only were they four
feet high but nobody believed me when I
went jogging I came back and I said I
got attacked by turkey it's all a rafter
is that correct the group called a
rafter big big there a there you go
those are the bad [ __ ] yes nuts
hanging off the front there beets I was
jogging and they just gonna fly I
started walking jogging towards me I was
like these turkeys are coming after me
and I had to turn and run my drug I come
and I go I got chased by turkeys they're
like [ __ ] I go cheetah come on the
stupid face well then I ran then I had
then we videotape chased me around a car
and I opened the door and they came at
my wife and she's freaked out how long
ago was this probably 10 years ago
almost I don't know but turkeys are
given dinner nice yeah I went to my dear
friend Taryn could turn kill him who you
know I love tuned Taryn his lovely wife
Coby they had a lot of an over their
house yeah
beautiful house they bought and it was
it was nice it was nice they had one
neighborhood Palisades and they had a
they had a chef come in and cook up I
mean a real turkey chef now we had
turkeys a heritage we had a heritage
turkey and a regular Turkey now the
heritage turkey is the kind of turkey
like that you got a turkey that
basically is you know shaped to run in
the forest now the turkeys wheat our
turkeys that their breasts have been
bred so large that they can't mate on
their own tits now she said she goes now
here's the heritage turkey and that's
the regular turkey you know between you
and me because I said this turkey is the
best turkey I've ever had I don't know
what you're doing she goes well I brine
it and I have a series of things to do I
go this is amazing because yeah the fake
turkey is better by the way in other
words the domesticated turkey not the
heritage is better than the r it's
better
there's just you see air man yeah not so
they're the chef cooked their turkey
well here's the thing though she has
some ass
haters she had some mashed potatoes okay
simili should well there's 88 975 people
so you have too long yeah so you said
they had it in you know you put it out
in silver trays right so people can come
Jesus Christ eighty people in the house
something like that
holy flus great though nobody's great
they're all friends of the party yeah
it's a party it was a party bingo
running charades it got crazy but either
way it was that she could make some
mashed potatoes and some sweet potatoes
chef bro
and then like white truffle macaroni and
this crazy [ __ ] that you eat where you
go like I put it on my plate and I was
like well this is a five-star restaurant
this isn't regular Thanksgiving and
Thanksgiving can be really good
yeah cornbread stuffing I ate so much
that I I've never I haven't had this
happen to me my body shot huh you ate a
ton my body shut down Isis flu nope but
I just I just I fell asleep on their
couch is very inappropriate and they
took pictures you don't do that you know
you know I thought it you know the old
guy yeah you know I'm the old guy Wow
who fell asleep because my body shut
down from so much sugar or something I
don't really show just getting older you
know yeah under the weather - well
nappy-poo I need a little was that all
that was on Thursday yeah I was gonna
say so Saturday we did the yeah we did
the fight campaign Saturday was fun it
was fun
I was I was doing everything in my power
to start a war between you and Eddie
Bravo
no no one bit we're gonna be like I told
him I said Eddie there's a worm hanging
don't take it you were so good cuz I you
were so convincing you're like but Eddie
I don't know what maybe you would know
feigning ignorance ain't nothing out of
any of you - I know I was hoping for
something well cuz it was the Sandy Hook
thing I was high - I wasn't that high
but I feel a little small I know better
than to take big ah
no way Rosen's got some it's very rare I
smoked ever he's got some [ __ ] that they
grow some working that strain cuz he's
on it it's like my coffee
you don't take a sip from my cup he's
gonna put [ __ ] here on your chest for
your girl yeah you know it's strong as
[ __ ] yeah then that's like Rogen's weed
it's not for the light of heart know
he'd smoked so much he can't just do
regular weed I love I love that
expression when I had a I was gonna buy
up Rottweiler and the guy knew
was a young man and he said one of his
dogs went you know what Jesus and he
goes yes he sees he said hey these dogs
are not for the faint of heart not the
latter heart for the faint of heart
and I went I know I'll take two I'll
take two I'm not [ __ ] yeah all right
Rogan and I were looking for pit bulls
and I wanted a badass pit bull and there
was an ad this is when we were young
idiots and it said pit bulls bred
straight out of the box that means
they're fighting dogs and I didn't want
to fight my dog but I wanted a dog to
look like yeah you know this is a
typical Bryan Callen this is you don't
want my dog to bite anybody you want
people to think you're tough through
your dog exactly exactly 100% yes and
even deeper psychology is now my other
friend who was a tough guy who went on
to be a special forces guy in Iraq he
goes hey why would you want a dog that
hates other dogs I love dogs why don't
you get a dog that doesn't like people
wouldn't you want a dog like a shepherd
that you can train to protect your house
no in case my dog gets bullied by
another dog this is how I was thinking
my dog can answer back this is the kind
of nutty [ __ ] that would go on my head
you ever this guy who bred his dogs was
probably not a good - he fought dogs but
he's also not a good guy I could tell
yeah then he gave his dogs I killed the
dog protein yeah protein powder yeah I
found out about that stuff because these
dogs lived our life at the end of a
chain and if they don't perform they get
put yeah it's terrible you know I mean
who the [ __ ] wants it's terrible yeah
you know what they do and opium they
also in they used to always do this back
in the day in the South they put a dog
pitbull in there in a huge pen full of
rats and the dog that could kill the
most rats in like a two minute period
one I don't know if that that's as warm
England no but they do that in the south
he's jetting south really it started in
England oh yeah oh yeah the staff Shire
tears is my pit bull in New York City
got a hold of a giant New York City rat
Italy hearts gonna scrap and Hills wrath
hurt oh no he's great she took I mean
I'm talking about a rat that was about a
foot long grabbed that [ __ ] rat and
shook it so hard
shook it in half and a piece of its gut
hit me right in the corner second could
be surprised yes so you get the rat tear
the Yorkshire Terrier Jack Russell
Terriers
yeah yes the small dogs that do work
leave that rat tear
oh yeah right Terry I'll take a little
rat too they go into tunnels I'll get
that [ __ ] go get those yes
rat ears keep scrolling down chin that's
a good-looking rat terrier oh these are
good - karent areas a great those are
cool
I love Karen Terriers yorkshire terrier
that's Krystal yes Julia does he know he
has to rash killers on a sense
well yummy not my dog my dog modem who
is not a big dog got ahold of one of
those dogs when I was a puppy I looked
down and my dog was had it that's bodies
about and shook it and killed it and I
said with that I cost me 2 grand and I
felt so bad for the woman but dog was a
probably the woman the vet said didn't
know it was a dog
because he wasn't being me that was a
toy [ __ ] sakes yeah did you see the
[ __ ] stupid picture daliyah post on
his Instagram he goes this is me I'm the
guy in the back and some guy has usually
got to go do this guy has his head in
the underwear and he and my dick is on
the back of his head and a good day the
[ __ ] is bad Julie goes guy in the back
is me my [ __ ] is all over the back of
the guy's head and here have a good day
everybody what the [ __ ] is that what is
going on now from a gay website yeah
yeah
well on the chest Lisa says 5 6 7
what does that mean I have no idea 5 6 7
get some random [ __ ] on the chest yeah
they also get some random dicks on the
back of their neck yeah that's how weird
is that
dicks dude speak up into dicks did you
see the Dwight Howard stuff no I heard
you talking about that my god all I know
hold on cuz Dwight Howard is you'd be
hard-pressed find a better more
impressive looking human base 10 foot
tall he's a beautiful man now proportion
skin cheekbones I mean he's good-looking
he's a seven-foot right now now now
you're gonna put power bottom and
there's no what are you talking about
his uh his boyfriend/girlfriend
apparently they throwing tires next-door
his girlfriend
transgender boyfriend outed him
basically um this is incredible
she has conversations tax and you know
the reason why she's doing it because he
his team gonna coat threatened to kill
her because she they wanted her signed
an NDA and she's like I'm not [ __ ]
doing that because I guess he cheated on
her and was like at these transgender
parties and hooking up with people and
now cheated on her and so she's lashing
out at him he's a he's a man who I think
a lot of women and other men would like
yeah apparently so hmm is he married no
he's so what so that wouldn't be gay
that'd be a guy who's into women guys
who dress up as women no he's gay okay
hold on because he's into dudes well
he's in with chicks with dicks he
thought like does she have a dick or is
she know she's transgender no so he's in
the chicks with tits in her
conversations like in the conversation
she's like Dwight you've told me you
love sucking dick and all this stuff
okay well but it doesn't matter no this
is dating history online so who knows
how trustworthy these things are but
just seeing if there's any I'm very
happy with all of them me too
they're all beautiful women but that's
also maybe you know yeah that's also
maybe right gods and transsexuals but
again I don't give a [ __ ]
well him but I gotta I'm confused now
because if he's into I need to know more
about this guy girl whoever I need to
know more is this little program gender
go to Instagram hit a full operator or
is this Fiona Instagram - she looks like
Dwight Dwight Howard she looks like
Dwight Howard mmm right I mean she looks
like Dwight Howard no she looks like
Kevin Garnett and drag well apples are
oranges but let me see what's going on
here
here's her Instagram followers huh
she also has a book coming out I think
so this is a little suspect industry hoe
industry hoe available but see but you
don't look at her and this isn't being
mean anything but I don't go oh that's a
female
no if you're Dwight Howard there's it's
not like wow that's something's going on
but if you read her whole timeline he's
going with the elixirs there's only
three three tweets in total yeah he
talks about all of it that's a that's
essentially a very effeminate man right
yeah that's like a that's like a good
twink so it doesn't look like she's
transgender it looks like he's a gay man
who likes to dress up like a woman am i
right yeah I says you're gonna have to
sew it says you're gonna have to learn
to hold your tongue or hold a gun zips
damn keeps what any other permission to
zone with that arrow I think right you
want to hear the voice who is that
crying there I don't know I'm not
talking about someone else
okay don't go off Yesi right like the
one on the right like it's not like oh
what that's a [ __ ] man but you know I
need to be even light in there look in
human being but yeah I'd say Dwight
Howard's better-looking Oh like there
you go okay that's a dude very thin
effeminate dude yeah okay that's what I
needed to say so Dwight Dwight us into
into that go to the video chin this one
or this one at all see what's confusing
is that that I'm I'm a little track we
can't see because he's a guy he's what
he's feminine no no sound like I can the
video of the there in the middle top
yeah
[Music]
hmm so super feminine so it almost feels
like he's you dead ass your dead ass you
can't be dead
this is what I waited for no take it
back
come on your dick is small its smallest
ow maybe he was agro maybe it was a
grower who knows full video on YouTube
famous toddler you serious
it's a little shady cuz she he has a
book coming out he that's a he yes and
to do what we called he write it's a
dude yeah but if she wants to be called
a she well if I want to be called
Donnell you're gonna call me Brian okay
call me Darnell okay Darnell I don't get
why do I care
definitely dude though very much a guy
yeah hmm what's your take man just a
game I need update we need update Brian
so bring up the tweets that she did we
need to update give Brian the full
update its right dude that she's got a
nice back uh I know it looks like Dwight
Howard she's between he's been tweeting
since all day um boy tweets a lot huh
yeah
oh [ __ ] look long story short B she just
kind of added him because you know
Dwight Howard if he is a gay man he
doesn't want that gun out so someone in
his entourage threatened her his life
I'm sure boyfriend's life yeah and so
he's like we you know if I don't miss
you know what this was happening that's
why he did it
yeah well maybe she got a little or he
got a little obsessed with Dwight and
Dwight was over it
no he cheated on her huh yeah there's
the Sheik record conversation like you
[ __ ] cheated on me hey Mimi almost a
month now I have a debate about being
about hit play what to do his kids
family it's just a story well I think it
sounds like maybe the life is life were
threatened so that's what this person
was saying that the pastor even was in
on it that says yeah then you're a dead
man walking so he was like [ __ ] this man
he's asked Dwight to help like don't do
this tell him to stop and it didn't stop
so he'd released all that stuff so he's
had a thing with her for a month it's
not very no way longer or longer where
do you see a month I thought I said a
month
no I'll through the season if they're
boyfriend-girlfriend dude my boyfriend
boyfriend what do you want God well what
it's not surprising they're gay athletes
out there oh well and there's a lot of
pressure
yeah I don't care not right there by the
way uh Jim I've also talked to very
famous people in a black community who
say that there's a shitload of pressure
in the black community to not come out
when you are supposedly straight but
that doesn't Buck has nothing to do with
it black white nobody should have to do
it it does in fact it doesn't because I
will tell you this right now there's a
shitload of I'm assuming there's a lot
of white gay no no I'm not talking about
that I'm talking about when you're black
in certain communities it is the black
community is pretty not only is it
religious but conservative in a lot of
places and so one of the things is like
when you come out it you know it's it's
it's a real thing or at least it's
that's how a lot of black
public figures feel I think to all
ethnicities but I don't think this is a
black or white thing
III why does it is no a little bit more
from what I'm just talking about what
I've become since I've had with famous
black people about this and it's like
it's a thing man
it's a thing for every more consistent
reveal then yeah it's a big deal what no
matter what it'd be less I think it's
less in certain in certain communities I
really do I don't know here but here so
in other words like you're used to being
in the NBA with your white or black came
out as yeah hey I don't think this is a
color thing it's a sports thing yeah
name the last guy who came out go the
guy what's that guy's Sam
last guy never played it down in the NFL
name another one and the oh and he's
black by the way name another one yeah
do you not just traveling just you guys
you're just with mystics just with the
statistics there's bound to be some gay
ones playing or my favorite out or Sarah
like there's a reason they don't come or
buy or do to [ __ ] guys once in a while
whatever it is you know I mean how do
sexualities complicated it's a spectrum
right it's a whole spectrum some people
are just aware people rate I don't give
a [ __ ] Dwight Howard's I don't know
anybody cares either I just think that
he cares we're talking about it is
because it's been kept a secret right so
so anything any time you have a secret
and it's out we all go oh [ __ ]
really no hoozy well especially that's
all fits Dwight Howard yeah because
that's why it's in our zone yeah my goes
there nobody got in trouble for using
steroids but people got in trouble for
lying about using steroids you know so
it you know I mean like what we get
interested
it's a weird test but he comes out says
yeah I did it I did it we are yeah I'm
gay you know that's cool it's what I'm
like like you and I and Chen hopefully I
don't know where did you own it if you
want a little weird about it but if you
own it it's it's gonna be the it's gonna
be less but when you get outed and we go
oh [ __ ] swells you outed like that yeah
yeah but when it would like we can say
oh it's cool it's all good I don't I
don't think the rest of society feels
that way
Dwight Howard well shun for the rest of
his career that which is why he thought
he had to send a death threat he's like
oh [ __ ] man because they're not accepted
I think what is it fifty percent of
transgender people commit suicide
or is it I think it's because of how he
is - is just he's a giant dude if it was
another like like smaller design or
widening [ __ ] it wouldn't last
that crazy or he's like smaller guy like
what if it was I don't even watch
basketball but I see Stefan curry all
the time like if you if someone says to
have a curry yes not as huge well also
though remember like and this doesn't
really apply to an athlete but it could
actually and I'll make at this point in
Hollywood when you were Kevin Spacey
coming up for example we all knew he was
gay for a long time but in Hollywood
your agent would always say you keep
that [ __ ] under wraps why because if you
don't nobody's gonna come see you in a
movie where you're making out with a
girl and you're the love interest that
was always the reason they'd always say
you got there too many roles where you
know all the roles are straight no no
gay roles if you would forget this back
then yep you'll forget this all time
when Will and Grace came along and it
was about to gay people see I remember
this is so interesting that was so
[ __ ] taboo that we were like what gay
characters about being about Brokeback
Mountain yeah but but Willis they offer
gay characters you know and with all the
black mountain-- was the first to show
two dudes [ __ ] [ __ ] yes like in a
major motion picture
yes and in love that's true and they
offered those roles to multiple big
names they are like I'm also so when
when the AIDS epidemic was happening and
people were dying and I'm again I was in
New York and I remember watching this
stuff it's really scary really terrible
and gay men were just decimated but what
you would hear a lot was first of all
that's what drove the sort of gay
movement a lot of it was but also you'd
hear people say things and good people
who were just very
they'd say things like well it's just
God God's punishing
you know being gay what do you want and
I'd hear that and I'd be like goddamn
man it was called the gay plague so to
see all this [ __ ] change so quickly but
then at the same time it's still taboo
so so with Dwight Howard here's my
question to you now that he's gay does
he sell as many jerseys no right maybe
that's why he does one come out right a
loose sponsorship yeah they'll say no
dude it's all good do what you want to
do all of a sudden it dies all in
anymore it dries out all of a sudden you
can't get on a team yeah we all say it's
all good but it's not all it's not it's
not and and and I and I know what the
owners are saying do we want a gay guy
in the locker room what does it do for
cohesion it's a lot it's a lot of like
press that we don't need right I mean
these are all the conversations they
happen behind closed doors but these
think Jay is if he is gay is the entire
career and he's been a fine teammate
he's had issues with Kobe and some other
guys but it's interesting though man oh
no exposes alleged audio yeah you have
got Gordon this made me laugh this made
me laugh harder than anything about this
yes now know before I say this I'm not
making live this situation I feel bad
for Dwight he's been outed
but whoever posted this you made me
laugh and it's a scene from Atlanta and
it's like this is here it is go to do
you go to app Willis underscore CJ on
yes yeah yeah twitter twitter this scene
is sums this up perfect at Willis
underscore CJ oops
now did 20 hours did Dwight Howard just
get transferred I mean to trade him well
he's on Washington so go down the scene
where to Atlanta you'll keep playing for
10 years right ball Herman yeah still a
beast Oh keep going how long how many
days ago is this play sure yeah you've
gone it's the Atlanta scene kook
geez oh wait let me just go to his
tweets and replies maybe then we'll do
it the tweets he sent it
oh wait go to well here it is go to app
while at ESPN I can send it to you at
what at Walid WOL ID Walid Walid yeah
Walid ESPN Wal ID ESPN there it is the
scroll down nope roll down keeps growing
it's Atlanta scene there it is play this
for private this is oh I remember this
scene to play this for Brian it was
before I'm call you honey I was in a
completely different space back then you
like to switch it up I can move if you
want ya know it's wild him back then
remember Larry no Larry
yeah Larry used to come around with
Kevin he went to Southwest I think so I
remember Kevin he was loud Larry came
with us to the movies that tongue I know
you remember to move we used to get
freaky in there all the time
quiet oh no used to get it in we stay at
now hey what's your problem
no problem I can move if you want I
don't ask you to move [ __ ] I'm trying
to talk to my girl you acting all weird
and [ __ ] yo girl
yeah man yo listen man we should talk
back after my mom's kicked me out of the
house my [ __ ] handsome man what nah man
it's my ex yo a girlfriend oh man why
you think she in jail wouldn't mean
she'd be on the other side [ __ ] you gay
no I mean she
there's a great thing okay great yo
[ __ ] is trippin myungjae y'all [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] guys up in here anyway that
a gay there's this dude use an outside
pocket booyah sexuality it's a special
you can do whatever you want
stab you all ass when you get upstairs
to themselves me [ __ ] sit up now I know
what y'all think she is
bring on that [ __ ] shipment stop being
weird I'm not I'm fine that's a great
scene I got a good actor too
yeah [ __ ] I gotta watch Atlanta I never
watched his games no good I bet Donald
cloggers killed damn he's the new liking
that seems so fun that's good he's like
nah man that's a that's a dude he's like
he goes yeah we [ __ ] booty holes in
prison that's prison though he [ __ ]
pretty goes on the outside funny we get
posted that right there two hours of us
lessons oh honey man and that funny yes
I remember that I tell you that kind of
magic white Howard though waking up this
morning oh that's tough nobody wants out
their dirty laundry that summer mm-hmm
socks man I mean I feel for him yeah god
I hate it I told you that time and
college where this dude
he was just kind of like just big and
pudgy and he was a masseuse and my back
always hurt
I didn't wrestle cuz my back hurts I was
always looking for somebody [ __ ] so
he gets in there and he starts getting
my taint
I go what's going on man he goes this is
where all your nerves are and that area
is where oh I didn't know he goes um
listen he goes this area is really where
your nerve center and I was calm enough
and you're gonna have to be I guess I'm
19 I don't know 18 you look like you
yeah I'm like [ __ ] and I was like you
like it old man dude he was like a like
a older you know junior or something and
I was like maybe a senior I was like oh
he's not no no I he wasn't on the team
he was just to do to my dorm who was a
masseuse and I'm like he had me turn
over or naked and I'm [ __ ] no I had a
towel ah but the [ __ ] is now
reaching in and doing this so I go I'm
like [ __ ] man I go well it's not that
comfortable he goes well you will get
comfortable and then I swear to god he
goes he goes ultimately what you want to
do is be able to put your fingers in the
anus and massage the nerve the cluster
of nerves that really relaxes your body
and I go okay man
well I'm gonna just turn over I just got
to get my lower back not that area he
did not get off my taint and and finally
he got to my lower back long story short
hard real hard
no I [ __ ] of course didn't but I was
like there was the most uncomfortable
[ __ ] I've ever had in my life now I find
out later on I go I'm I go uh now did he
eat my buddy Dan goes yup he did that
[ __ ] to me he did that [ __ ] to me but I
also know a bunch of guys that got their
[ __ ] sucked on this [ __ ] right now I
know what I mean cuz he was tight with
the dude oh wow and he talked about two
dudes who couldn't been more macho one
dude was from the Middle East
get macho is [ __ ] his dick thug and
and he he blew both of them and I go I
go and I Merced and I said I go I don't
even want to say his name out loud but
let's the same his name is Hassan I go
Hassan and he goes well he's Arab so you
know we I was like what do you mean
these Arabs I think that's not gay
it was just so funny yeah he's cool with
gay he was a gay he was a gay man he
loved your school was a gay man what he
did was he was a gay man he goes I'm
gonna figure out a way to suck their
sous I'm a masseuse and I'm gonna come
up with a new technique and there's
gonna be a couple guys that are gonna
bite and they bid and they bet and they
bit put your finger in my
oh there's oh it's in my butt now
dawn why you're not changing the story
it's a blur braless yo I'm not in a
court of law
man I never told you why would I tell
you this we got molested by the camp cam
while that was a long time ago I'm pet
some [ __ ] happened in your booty but you
know no not my booty sorry sir well I'm
just saying that general area nine ever
what was that dead Johnny buff Davidoff
on a true story guy said I'll give you
my baseball cards because he goes look I
took a light molestation when I was a
kid I'll be honest with you guys showed
me some baseball cards and let me see it
I showed it to him you know maybe
touchdown remember and he goes either
way a lot of people call that mal
station I call it a good deal [ __ ] man
yeah Howard that's tough dude uh-huh
that's tough I feel for him I really owe
you know how we were talking about that
Satan Island with those Sentinel island
yeah I called Satan 9 and how that guy's
buried well they went to go get the body
I had to turn around because they came a
full force where the arrow is bone
arrows we had to turn around my thing is
what you think was gonna happen those
rescuers what you think yeah but mine I
get that body just get some tear gas oh
you could they don't want to do that any
of that to them
so they're just right there even the guy
right in the is basically his frickin
suicide letter before I went in there
goes no need to try and recover the body
if this doesn't go well all right so he
can't touch them because they'll get
diseased I mean you can't they don't
have any immunity so there's all kinds
of issues there well knew he was gonna
die like you know he went there the
first time paid them illegally to go
there and he was up they threw a arrow
that his Bible through his Bible that he
stopped he yelled and went laughs that
went came back and was like man I just
feel like they need the word of Jesus
Christ and they're like what arrow
through the face yeah this guy this guy
was a suicide mission I don't think it's
all there I was about to say I just
don't feel like somebody like that it's
all there no I don't like you know hold
on I'll tell you right now if I showed
up to Stuart tomorrow someone's thrown a
[ __ ] arrow through a book I have in
my hand I'm like that oh [ __ ] I'm not
going back tomorrow but if you read the
New Testament I mean Paul on his road to
Damascus Saul you know on his road on a
donkey Saudis
on his road to Damascus fell over went
blind for three days he was a rabbi he
was a Jewish rabbi and a real zealot and
in fact was respond was commissioned to
persecute Christians fine Christians and
persecute them put them in jail whatever
it was on the road to Damascus falls off
his donkey sees God sees Jesus Jesus
says why are you essentially why are you
persecuting my followers why are you not
taking me as your Lord three days later
he gets converted and Paul if you look
at the Old Testament I mean the New
Testament it's essentially letters he
wrote to different churches that he
established in Turkey and all over the
place
establishing how to run a Christian
Church and what the Word of God was B
never met Jesus I think this guy's
thinking ahead it's the same idea right
I was thinking that but he's a convert
and the convert was you have to go and
you have to the Christian mission is to
go and convert spread the word yeah
spread the good news that nyle a well
don't go to Sentinel island Satan Island
and also said oh we tosser your you
carry diseases that could have wiped all
of them out so I agree with you i I I
couldn't agree more but they are an
aggressive group huh Jesus Christ relax
Oh white Devils let us then see some
more pictures of them are there any
video of them
yeah there's video id' it's very
interesting that he knew how dangerous
was and still went you gotta think a
little mentally unstable their devil or
intelligence or the guys like I know
nobody else did but I'm the one all the
angels fear to tread here but I'm the
angel that does tread and he was worried
well hey you don't speak their language
[ __ ] right I think he's looking for I
think he knew he's gonna die yeah I
don't think he's all this is fascinating
though right isn't that fascinating you
a helicopter flew over and they tried
shooting down the helicopter there uber
aggressive on an island what's the
bloody ones to the left there that them
chin no that's another tribe and that's
another amazing tribe in the Amazon that
they call you know there's over a
hundred tribes like this they said I bet
I mean in the middle of the Amazon I
mean it's an amazing covered in red do
you see I mean it's [ __ ] cold if we
went down
my phone told him it's magic you know
look at that is that them your t-mobile
bill that is amazing to me but you can't
be all they arrested the guys who
brought them there for murder
the guys who illegally paid to bring
them to the chase their sunny dollars
those it dude look at those long bows so
there's no actual video just pictures no
there's a very blurry video of them like
firing at a helicopter but it looks like
that it's not great dude murder ain't no
thing look at that
you know what they need they need some
comedy bro show it's a no-go go back
down there's the Sentinelese I'm so
fascinated people who haven't been
touched which one to the far right down
down right Yeah right there let me see
that
you should get touching mombi oh yeah
I'm very that statue was a beautiful
people well that's what human beings are
wouldn't get care to it was beautiful
but well I'm just saying you want to
touch him brother get in there bro they
should just let you get in and get your
hands wet well alright that's him
African look at that [ __ ] the sentence
from Africa like the original their
aggressive now be careful yeah yeah Wow
look at that and then sort of tits on
that dude in the front there I think
that's a girl oh yeah pink song that is
so fascinating well know what it's like
day-to-day in that village boring is
shareable for 5000 Alex get your dicks
out long arrows that they fashioned from
oh that they spend all day in Milan the
size of man so that what they probably
do is get fish in all kinds of [ __ ]
didn't us talk about this too this one
says they gave me coconuts and I was
fine but then this guy was trying to
give him some other stuff or didn't have
food and that's why they kill it like
attacked him on phy companion well we
didn't talk about that yeah well well
they once they trade a one guy came back
out he was fine and they were cool yeah
but home break-in with the Bible yeah
that should I
they had they got metal they took some
metal from somewhere but yeah the the
the Pope oh yeah they've got that metal
but this dude came with coconuts like I
dude you cool with us these are tasty of
[ __ ] homeboy can't the Bible and they
went cool story here's an arrow through
the face yeah what's fascinating to me
is that they're violent regardless of
any other contact didn't give anyone a
chance well think about it though
they're smart they'll because you know
they could they know that they take it
die exactly it's illegal to go there
because they don't have the same immune
systems that ice that's right crazy yeah
that's amazing
the those people in that Amazon the ones
there they were shooting arrows at the
planes - yeah like right down there and
we don't get too feisty cuz someone
could just come over the helicopter and
a [ __ ] machine gun and take care of
your in your village they're not aware
of that with yes technology can do that
you just have to say that out loud just
see you guys now if we wanted to well
they're listening to this if you see an
idea where products have just of what's
like generations of idea sharing hat
well we don't know yeah the last thing
they know less white boy they saw came
the island [ __ ] half the human beings
is an amazing book about this where they
talk about a human he makes a point
human beings get smarter because we mix
and share from each other we don't
actually smarter we don't just innovate
we innovate when we come into contact
with people the [ __ ] was he thinking mom
reveals all this is his vlog before he's
killed
no his mom that's some said something
the mom forgives the tribe she said
strikes uber religious cuz I'll tell you
right now if they killed one of my
family members we're going we own
Blackwater and I'm showing up like cool
arrows here's an Uzi Brennan you can't
just go in machine gun them all Brandon
they're black water bro they're the last
tribe touch my family we're gonna have
to get down no you have to pray for make
a movie about it pray for them and
for love and then I'm gonna write my own
[ __ ] Pearson also you raised my son
you raised your son and you say you
don't just go to some random island in
the middle of nowhere
even if Jesus lived on yes Jesus is
wrong and when you see that your son is
maybe a little bit of a fanatic or maybe
a little bit of went to what's the word
yeah fanatic went too far down the
rabbit and then you have to yeah there's
something go down yet really mentally I
don't want to blame his parents of
course who would literally go anywhere
else in the world
yeah see his last statement no what'd he
say so his final note to his family says
you guys might think I'm crazy in all
this but I think it's worthwhile to
declare Jesus to these people god I
don't want to die you know what he was
doing yeah there you go well you know
what he must have got shot right through
the baby flying aircraft right so his
last name's chow so there's some Asian
there Chinese if the whole thing is
interesting I just want to know where
the [ __ ] sixty thousand years the
Andaman Islands I mean think the people
go by it all the time and then he put he
wrote violence why does this beautiful
island have so much death here I hope
this isn't one of my last notes but if
it is God be the glory of God be the
glory he knew he was gonna die for God
say yeah
there it is how that's the island look
at that [ __ ] island looks gorgeous I
know in the middle of nowhere
very very forested I can't believe no
[ __ ] me nuts the size of man nobody
no one's taking that place over made it
a [ __ ] cool spot destination well
it's two in the middle of nowhere where
do they get their fresh water from
that's what I'd like to know I'm sure
they figured it out yeah wells are
Springs yeah he put I've been so nice to
them why are they so angry and so
aggressive now he can't be all there if
he's saying that and wondering input
doing this to establish the kingdom of
Jesus on the island do not blame the
natives if I
killed oh we don't oh it's such a shame
man
he just went he just got too deep into
it yeah yeah and those people have not
found Jesus and that's the real tragedy
here and they're gonna pay for this
because they need that even though it's
gonna pass nearest they're gonna pay
when they say you guys know forgiveness
and love it's a shame though yeah I
wonder what their mythology is I wonder
what they do believe in they probably
carried it up killing white Devils well
that's what they celebrate well yeah
because of their history is that him
that's him he seems like a good dude
loved God loved helping those in need
you have been a little unstable though
there you go there man yeah yeah so you
have a death wish you know I again
there's something wrong with him you
know I mean that's his mission to just
go all over the world and how come one
person like bro you know they speak zero
English right and he's like the most
dangerous place on earth there's always
a tradition Kellie cat in the house he
did not need to come town cat coming in
you're the day off girl badass we're
talking about this kid a basic him in
suicide going to Satan Island oh I heard
about that yeah they had police had to
leave right yeah let's get the by real
quick and those Islands said not up in
here yeah leave the body it's ours now
yeah you gotta leave the body that's a
grim job we're gonna dig the body up
recover your own though you know no man
falling behind yeah unless he fell
behind st. Nazaire tribesmen then you
might have to use tear gas yeah it's so
easy yeah you know what you do you super
easy you get one of those those laser
pointers put them in their eyes for a
little bit you think the body out it's
so easy turn your iPhone [ __ ]
brightness up all the way put on their
stupid eyes just just release a couple
of tigers on the aisle yeah we can't
really control the Tigers know it kill
those Tigers probably knows you'd fly
over and just drop a bunch of [ __ ]
date rape drugs
party up yeah and then they just [ __ ]
broken sound they all passed and chillin
the booty then you get the body
hmm hmm I wonder what they're like on I
wonder like a lot of times tribes that
have not been contacted aren't so easy
on their women I attended two weird
dances oh you mean they don't have equal
rights yeah liberal ideas you mean if
you if we turn about the me to movement
they would shove off spear through our
mouths yeah they'd kill you yeah yeah
hear me out fellas listen I see Ramona
over there doing all the work well when
you kill somebody for just showing up at
your front door you know I mean when
that did you're probably not the most
liberal minded person you know I'm
saying so I would like to go there
though yeah yeah well I would too now
I'm curious what if you went as
chocolate body the well the badass thing
that do beat against tea mist Navy SEALs
hear me out in camo sneaked on the
island and then just take video like you
to say your job is just to videotape
them and stuff well we get a drone just
feel like once the top of the well I
don't think last scene in there cuz they
live in the forest it looks like I'll be
crazy when the drugs we hope these days
oh yeah but you're still densely yeah
they're on the outskirts but swap my
wife but do it with one of them there
was one guy that's not allowed to be
contacted his whole entire tribe was
killed by loggers and there's he was
left loggers which along had it they had
a video of him chopping a tree down
what's a logger
um just guys you come on we're illegal
loggers I'm like in laughs yeah there's
a lot of illegal
damn thing like the [ __ ] one to
chocolate booty on the left there oh
well you saw that damn right I saw it
what lost tribe is that that is a that
is open road dark woman bust ass okay
well it is but that's a dark woman -
dude that is a dark chocolate ass I'm
not mad at you and demands an ax man let
me see that picture of her again you you
you drop
they did further laughter they look like
she killed this guy no wonder he's going
on as a different you have a tribe look
at that that's a different time
oh the Negrito people of the animals
she's been she's got a a net and any
[ __ ] dark booty that's the dark booty
dude bodied up though get you nipple out
of my face but bodied up yeah she's
brought it out music sweet lady no not
mad at her at all no I'm kind of drawn
to her huh dad asks just glistening in
the tropical weather there yeah got my
eye uh how do we're talking on this
murder you're kind of big guys come in
they're all tan no she put me in that
net and email life I don't want to go
there it's not that bite they're out
there they are out looking for food yeah
I don't know so bomber either way a guy
did die yeah but you kind of asked for
it Danny
mm-hmm yes ask for it dude hunting
fishing collecting watch dude you're
trying to go to the fight to Saturday
huh I am but I think I'm gonna stay at
home drink some good wine eat some good
cheese and watch the fight this is
because I didn't get your tickets yeah
but I think that it's better to wash it
off wait are you right well you better
do you really want to go to traffic and
sit no not me I'd much rather be at home
so secretly I'm kind of happy that you
can't get tickets I thought I had a
contact with you and you will Feldman
took my tickets I've already got him I
got his crew tickets like months ago
though bro it's only the biggest fight
of the year you asked me the week no no
you asked me tickets literally no you
told me I said I should have known
um yeah uh good for you are they good
seats oh did you get Todd good seats I
would imagine right yeah okay is that
yeah well ringside cuz they're not a
fighting cage yeah you know what though
again let me say it again it's to I'd
rather watch you from I'd rather watch I
feel like I'm doing you I don't like
service crowds I just don't it's such a
hassle to go this ass
it's fun but it's not anyway did though
dude huh dude I'm doing your old
stomping grounds New York City yeah I'm
jealous
I love leo I Love New York what else
happened I took my kids to a giant
hamster wheel where kids can run in it
is that there's a yeah there's a in
LaVista there's a dog adoption center
I've never seen anything like it in my
life the Annenberg pet a new dog no but
you can adopt these dogs they live in
basically luxury hotels I've stayed in
the hotels that are not as nice so why
take the duck the dogs probably love it
they love it and and but they have a
giant hamster wheel there and all I had
to say with my kids are you guys want to
go play on a giant hamster wheel and
they all went oh yeah yeah so this ran
in the Sam sir wheel seems a little
dangerous guess super boring after about
one minute yeah yeah what they don't did
Dave and Buster's my kid one less thing
we went there uh about a month ago yeah
nasty don't like it no don't like the
food don't like it the video games suck
yeah run down I started getting carsick
from a video game oh really which one um
it was one others and you had ones but I
was shooting and sitting down in cover
and I was like I'm getting sick watching
this like carsick I had my son had fun
for about 30 minutes things I carried
him over this yeah yeah I wasn't into it
it's so hot in here right I'm sorry
no I'm not I just yawned for no reason I
ate before I came here
would you eat chicken salad this is
really cool blackened chicken Cajun
south don't they really cool though
super cool and that's a very weird to
say I had an almond all right I don't
know coffee drink or some [ __ ]
genius the current events yeah we got
for you here's uh the first one cat
so Kevin Hart and his wife and Nico
current I think on Thursday had their
baby's first birthday party and it was
Indians and cowboys themed and social
media
lost their mind Oh social media go [ __ ]
yourself I'm alive because they're
Indians I don't know I just saw that
Indian people like this is offensive oh
that's so [ __ ] dumb go [ __ ] yourself
you virtuous signaling your moral
posturing stand be like them from Satan
the Tukey they're little kids [ __ ] off
moral posturing it's a first birthday
listen this isn't it far left inside
masses they won't even let kids why
about yourself this wants somebody to
cry about
they're so dumb they look for anywhere
anyway by the way who gives a [ __ ]
exactly or a bunch of dummies on social
media yeah you don't really change
anything that I'm just cry on there no
one really reads the comments yes it
seems like half of the people are super
offended and then the other half are
making routing that no are hoping that
an eco and Kevin Hart
don't apologize for this cuz it look
what the [ __ ] do not the first year old
everything doubled down and that Kevin
should dress up as an inn I agree for
Christmas that's what I would do a lot
of people are arguing that this is their
version of I believe the term that was
used was intersectional appropriation Oh
intersectional appropriation so in other
words let me let me just face let me
just address that so you know what that
means
so your first of all you were
appropriating another culture and that's
offensive the problem is we all
appropriate culture this country was
founded on the idea that we [ __ ] when
you're wearing if you're wearing a suit
and a tie that's appropriating British
culture if you're using math that's
appropriating so Scottish to the music
it never ends
so our country is great because we are
probably tous a cultural appropriation
it's delicious rice from China doesn't
come from a culture of vultures
yeah cows come from Europe you know you
put it all together cheese comes from
where France or they say it started in
Turkey another Switzerland
or is it Swiss on either way it's all
delicious you mix it all in with
tomatoes and peppers women from South
America
that's what cultural appropriation is
how we get smarter you dumb [ __ ]
that's why this country is great because
we're a melting pot they're so [ __ ]
dumb so what they want to do is separate
cultures because since you your skin or
your origins are from somewhere else
you can't enjoy
someone else's culture they're so dumb
they're so dumb and intersectional but
notice anyone who's doing anything in
their life aren't there the problem is
that these [ __ ] are coming out
of academia and they're controlling like
human resources departments and [ __ ]
and companies at Google they're they're
bad people [ __ ] that man I'm telling you
it's getting worse and worse
intersection is too so so it's like you
these kids okay you know that works so
you're a woman right okay now but then
again white women have it better what
about black women black women but when
they have these rallies it's [ __ ]
hilarious you know what happens in these
rallies so they're intersectional
feminist movements so the black women
they've suffered more so they have
higher status but then what about black
women with lupus black women with
allergies they were breaking up into
these different groups Jesus Christ
wharves you gonna double down after
Kevin Hart these people are doing this
they're not doing [ __ ] there's crying
online boring what else get individuals
so the Thanksgiving Parade that Macy
Macy's puts on every single year this
year there was a lot of controversy
behind it because a Broadway show called
prom is actually went and performed a
piece and at the end they had the two
leads kissing and there are girls so a
lot of people were complaining about how
the Macy's parade is traditionally
family-friendly and this year they
didn't want the kids to watch women
kissing isn't family friendly let me see
it they like the video it's like really
small as towards the very end a
attractive I'll tell you right now if
you're watching this [ __ ] parade it's
not friendly to your family some boring
[ __ ]
[Music]
well it's probably always been really
gay so come on oh here they go push the
envelope
oh no that's a that's a Broadway kiss
dude I got a lot of parents like hey I
got explain this to my kids and I
haven't yet you know I mean I don't need
you [ __ ] telling him so I get it at
the end of the world yeah but there was
that and then Twitter uh basically
[ __ ] on Rita Ora because there were
some issues with the technical side of
the parade and Rita Ora didn't hit her
mark and it was exposed that she was
lip-syncing lip-syncing but everybody
loves you can't make him happy did you
see John Legend came out went hey who's
one of the best yeah singers on the
planet of all time goes hate to tell you
guys they're not those those rafters
whatever the [ __ ] those those parade
floats those boats they're not set up
for the coup Stickley to carry the
equipment everyone who's ever done that
parade has Lipson that's what you do
yeah let me see hers do we have it no
search it up yeah so John Legend camera
defense like hey tell you when I did it
you have to lip thing during those think
you don't have the capabilities to carry
all the equipment right but I'm sure
people [ __ ] give it to her nasty
sound very sexual and I would give it to
her nasty cuz she's a die me die me and
her new song is pure fire she's
Australian I think all right now looking
the best there
[Music]
oh wow it's way off that's just a glitch
to get song enough oh it's way off that
poor girl prade's are so old school so
boring I agree awesome our site but also
Rina don't dress like that we're cold
that's cold called New York baby so have
you guys heard about the Dolce & Gabana
controversy that happened last week no I
have not
so Dolce & Gabana was scheduled to have
a fashion show a very large fashion show
in Shanghai last Wednesday and a few
days prior they released three videos on
Instagram as a tribute to China because
within the buying market Chinese and
Middle Eastern people have the most
buying power right now and they bun so
they're trying to like create these like
large extravagant shows in China and the
Middle East and for their Chinese show
they had three videos with this Chinese
model who was where this voice in the
back would teach her how to eat Italian
foods with chopsticks like pizza and
condom and a cannoli and spaghetti and
there were very mixed reviews about that
nobody thought it was racist they just
thought it hit the mark cuz the one with
the cannolis like Oh your chopsticks
aren't used to such a large item and
little things like that and a few days
later somebody who I believe had maybe
like 2 4 thousand followers on Instagram
a small blogger deemed Dolce Gabanna
Gabbana I believe their actual Instagram
as well as Stefano Gabbana's like
personal Instagram and he replied back
calling China a [ __ ] a [ __ ] country
saying that well if you feel that your
being Asian
like this was making you feel inferior
then that probably means that you
already believe yourself that Chinese
people and Asian people are inferior and
so a patient official apology they did
and they actually had to shut their show
Wednesday morning even though the show
was scheduled for Wednesday evening so
they shut it so basically because they
she was using chopsticks eat Italian
food it wasn't necessarily the videos it
was his tweets and he's no replied
through the DMS he's actually known for
being super controversial and saying
things that does not help his brand like
he called Selena Gomez ugly and one of
those like Instagram photos or it's like
Oh her and red dresses which one does
she look great in and he was like she's
so ugly and he backtracked because all
of her fans came out and started
attacking him and he said oh no I meant
the dress is ugly but one of the dresses
she was wearing was a Dolce & Gabbana
dress he also called Kate Moss ugly
he had liar no he's I think like a
40-something year old hey I mean that's
a caddy he's old enough to know better
than to be reckless on social media
Jesus Christ it's a it's a rather what's
the word I mean that's a huge market it
is a huge market Chinese buy up all the
brands and what he ended up doing to
backtrack from his DMS was he took a
screenshot of those games that went
viral
posted it on his page on his Instagram
story with big italics not me trying to
say oh my account got hacked and then he
came out and said that the Dolce and
Gabanna account got hacked as well
because somebody also deemed their
account and somebody replied back do you
think your posts scare us do you think
we're gonna backtrack we're not scared
of some small bloggers and dolce gabbana
came out with a photo saying that both
accounts got hacked and they're trying
to backtrack that way but if you look
into his past you could see the verbage
we haven't sorted everything that's just
what he does he's worth 1.5 billion so I
hope oh he's definitely gonna be okay
let's see the the apology do they give
it a Polish yeah that's your standard
mall shitty Oh
okay he's gonna be fine because Dolce
and Gabanna isn't owned by a parent you
guys are so cold there's a warm are they
doing an Italian I believe so yes
granted especially to talk well okay J
so J so equal okay [ __ ] cows at door guy
on the left looks like he's been up all
night
and that's duty itchiness in El Mundo
the kitchen is so no more today in the
motor seriamente questo with the schools
i equates the massager
she almost simply number at the yeah
cookie cutter [ __ ] what else you got key
cutter so what just looking at this
photo what would you think this girl is
black racially black no I would say
black really I don't know Latin black
something that yeah but I guess she has
a pretty large Instagram following and
somebody found photos of her that do not
look like that and she it came out that
people are asking her like oh do you are
you trying to come off as I believe the
term was somebody a colored person and
she said no this is just the way I like
to do my makeup and the white girl is
how she used to look like what what Wow
yes some people call her a poulter
vulture but also I've seen comments that
people are mad because it's like yes it
is blackface to a lot of people but it's
done so well that they're not mad at it
cuz she looks good and she's races hot
she's she's also from Sweden so they
don't have the same type of like
cultural understanding America it
doesn't mean she's being she's very
it's like she's trying to get a black
eye she's sexy and looks very sexy but I
don't think she necessarily looks white
I'm an amazing job good god it's a lot
of work because you're buying me on the
left there already is yep
make you young yeah she looks good
either way either way yeah that must
take forever to become chocolate face
though fam she is stunning though
yeah I'm really hope no hate on her with
us yet
are these didn't well there's this all
right you saw this pretty amazing voice
hi guy accidentally kicked the referee
as they're trying to break them up and
knock them down oh right in the nose
that's gotta hurt like a [ __ ]
alright this
announcer just a little over oh you got
kicked right in the nose it's not like
it ripped his head off good for him he
stepped right into that kick it's gotta
hurt
what else yet you know kicked the old
chops yup kick to the nose I'll drop you
quick huh unfortunately that neck guy he
was arrested again well that's not me
this time I think they're trying to get
him really cuz yeah well he had like.he
give them real bad history of crime gin
all right well it was his marijuana
possession he was neck out of it
Connie's up to his neck in trouble come
on Brandon seriously anyone any lewd
wonder what happens next
oh don't be thick thick-headed will you
stick your neck out on the line
alright yeah the guys out there
essentially emotionally naked so that
neck has a mother you know you heard
this new thing necrophilia all right
what's next what's new you got arrested
again for just being a complete [ __ ]
crazy changing lanes spired license of
MyPyramid a human pyramid but speaking
the same guy do you get arrested for
imitating a thumb I've seen people get
arrested for imitating a stingray what
else you got it tells me it's a stingray
I've seen tattoos he looks like a human
arrow it looks like a stingray yeah um
hey yo so this guy's also there's an MMA
organization that wants him to fight
either in MMA or boxing well don't
good luck choking them Island good luck
choking him out though I mean going gay
he does fight no no he doesn't know
background so kind of like you know
because he's big in the news right now
that money I'm Jesus Christ what an
embarrassment embarrassing is [ __ ] I
love that come fight know he hasn't made
some of the best choices in life in the
past so maybe something like this would
be good be a good step in the right
direction well I disagree I feel like
ting get the CEO said that what a
terrible thing what else that is pretty
much it that's if kids you guys all
right yeah poor neck dude man porn
actors right Brendan where you gonna be
um it's so hot in here man it's draining
our energy we're a little hot it's so
hot
it was a Monday was a mellow Monday
mellow Monday dude I don't for a hot
second Monday Monday Monday the gym and
try get my next says is the net guy
that's what I'm gonna do that's a good
idea to ride a Saturday I'm in New York
City New York City Friday Gotham
Saturday Gotham New York City then next
week I'm in Albuquerque New Mexico two
shows Friday to show Saturday then the
only other dates besides I'll be at the
Comi storm there this Tuesday but the
other only other one December just went
live the I South Pasadena December 28th
29th and then finally we got the link up
for Edmonton Canada Edmonton coming
January 10th and 12th and then the
granja go so the January 19th San Diego
get your tickets now tea fat K calm a
bikini shirts will be available this
week we're hoping those will be up and
New York OC Friday Saturday Jan 31 kids
Irvine improv them bring oh you're back
yeah you go back on their own that's
when it starts brother oh I got my
February dates and my March to achieve
fat K Tom y'all yeah they gets less then
stay do see out there this is the fine
kid we're out